i'm kind of different because i'm also a
woman
but i'm also jews so it's being it's
like being a minority within a minority
i call it like that
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctek
for this episode of 20 minute leaders
i'm joined by susan zaher
software developer and team lead at code
value susan is a 26 year old drew's
israeli married woman
a software developer and a team lead in
the high tech industry in code value
she is working on a project of a complex
imagery analysis system
integrating solutions for presenting a
big amount of two-dimensional and
three-dimensional imagery data in web
platforms
and seeking to be an influencer in the
tech industry
suzanne zahr thank you so much for
joining me on 20 minute leaders how are
you
thank you michael for having me i'm very
excited actually to talk to you today
i'm fine how are you i'm doing great
thank you where where are you calling
from right now
actually from my home i'm sitting uh
in the dining room so i actually can see
everything perfect and where is where is
home right now where in israel
i live in the deleted caramel uh
it's a village uh drew's village on the
mount
uh carmel uh the caramel mountain so uh
yes beautiful well it's a place that i
visit
very very often and uh you know and and
i like that that's
you know we're starting our conversation
um usually talking about the journey of
the person and what they do and then the
higher trend of of their domain
expertise and
and today you're a team leader at a code
value
an engineer and not a trivial path
i think from one i understand from your
background to become an engineer let
alone a team leader
and and definitely a a big influence in
the jewish community and we'll get to
that as well
and your perspective on that and and the
impact there but suzanne take me a
little bit throughout your
your personal journey how do you find
yourself you know as a team lead
at code value uh okay so
almost maybe uh eight years ago i really
had
no relationship to code or software
uh almost no exposure or awareness to it
i really had no idea back then what i'm
going to do
as i grow up but i know i was going to
do something interesting
and important so um really after
graduating from school i was considering
different
things to do uh eventually i found that
like industrial engineering very
interesting as a profession where it's
all about
a process optimization in companies and
complex system
so it's all about solving big problems
and offering
uh smart solutions so i started a
studying
uh in the technion and institution of
technology and
from there i had to do some mandatory
courses
uh so really in my first semester which
included actually introduction to uh
computer science
i immediately fell in love and i
found a really deep interest of how
computer works and i felt kind of
natural connection to this kind of
thinking
the way computer thinks or operates
so it was so rational and it made sense
so i decided uh um to go in that way
and major in information system where i
took computer science
courses and eventually uh in my last
semester
um i started a boot count in code value
almost
for for almost six months i think our
eventually i was
ready to work as a software engineer um
so this is my way uh to code value in
how i
get into the tech industry
so you know most people that i have on
the show and i think
this the current story of most engineers
unfortunately
and most there's always the anomalies is
that you know they grow up almost with a
computer in their hands and they're
surrounded by people that are engineers
and and it's almost
you know from the moment that you go to
first grade you know okay i want to be a
computer engineer
was that the case for your end is this
is this the environment that you grew up
in no
actually i had no connection to it i i
was
like i was a good student i was a good
student in school
uh but i i know i knew i was going to do
something important but i really didn't
know what i'm going to do
and so no there was no
no connection to computers or uh or
technology maybe
so uh but i found like when i when i
just
started studying like i saw i was
open-minded
and i saw a lot of uh domains that i can
go
and really influence and actually i see
uh my profession being a programmer or
being a software engineer uh or me
it's like for me influencing and doing
um
really doing things that it's a tool for
me to influence and do uh things
uh in today's world so this is actually
how i look at it it's
uh it's more like a way of life rather
than just being a
profession or a job a daily job to do
right yes right and so
to so you know as you progress in you
you
get into the world of engineering and
you become a software engineer and a
team leader okay
tell me what surprised you along this
along this path what did you learn about
this industry or this ecosystem that
you know growing up you didn't
necessarily expect
okay so um actually i bring
when i when i do this work uh i i
you need to learn uh how you need to be
really open-minded again
so you need to see everything you need
to uh
see the whole picture you need to
understand how the
what the client's needs what are the
needs for the client
and you need to also to build the right
team
uh with the right people with the right
technology stack in order to achieve
what you want to do
so it's all about uh
learning along this process i know how
you bring your uniqueness so you use
you learn from the best from your from
your teachers experts in the company but
you also bring
your own uh to everything you have to
bring your own to everything
so for me it's bringing uh because
i'm actually different i'm different i'm
i'm kind of different
because i'm also a woman but i'm also
drews so
being it's like being a minority within
a minority i call it like that
so yes so yeah so i'm also
bringing uh uh also being a minority
in that in that in that the gender
aspect
but also i'm bringing my culture with me
uh
my beliefs my life into work into my
daily work
uh so i think you have to bring it you
to bring your own into
your daily job and that's when you make
things
special that when things uh uh
you make you make different things
very very cool and let's let's continue
on this
minority within a minority because you
know it's an important subject yes
it's not being talked about it enough
and and i think that even when it is
being talked about i think that
we're lacking the the real you know
personal aspect and where it actually
meets you and what you know from inside
you actually observing
so so talk to me i would love to first
understand a little bit better
you know the jerus community and you
know the reason i was asking before
about your upbringing is that
you know the jews community is an
integral part of of israel and the
israeli ecosystem
it is not yet an integral enough part of
the high-tech industry and
and i think thanks to people like you
hopefully hopefully very soon it will
become
but tell me a little bit about this
about the jerusalem and what you're
observing
uh so we want to talk about the jewish
community i think uh uh
maybe 1.4 of the total population israel
are jews
so uh the jews are really arabic
speaking
arabic speaking but what makes us unique
is because we serve in the idf these are
defense forces
so yes so this is what really makes us
unique
it's not just about that it's more than
that it's not just
uh serving in the military because we
really the feeling of belonging is what
makes us different
uh we really feel belong to this place
so um actually more than it's a
population jerusalem
actually a religion so if you want to to
know about it more it's it's esoteric
monotheistic so we believe in one god we
are kind of secret
religion uh so only the people that are
religious
uh really uh read from the holy book and
really understand the religion
um but we're
so yes you said it uh everything it's
not perfect okay so
we're it's not like everything perfect
here in this country
but i'm saying that we're we're we want
to fight
for uh for for for us uh
it's not just we're fighting the country
like we're fighting for it
okay so we want to be part of this place
so yes you talked about the high-tech
industry and how we can uh uh bring more
people to the
more juice people to the high-tech
industry and it's all about awareness
it's all about
uh to know this population to know this
uh community uh to learn about it more
uh to visit their people and maybe to
start uh more um investing in the
education system
and uh and bringing awareness to all to
all this
industry that really can make change so
you can see
so people can get know it better and be
aware of it
um that's it i think this is one one of
the things that i do
right now is really uh doing that like
people can look uh at me and say okay so
there's a lot of
women and people and drews that can
really be in the
in the high-tech industry
right and so within the jewish community
um
how how how much is it integrated into
the israeli tech ecosystem today
i think there is a lot of uh jewish
people in the uh
tech industry maybe not enough again
because of the
the separate education system we have
really separate
from uh we we don't learn
uh uh computer science uh maybe today
more but
back then i think when i was uh in high
school
uh i didn't learn uh computer science i
didn't
i wasn't aware to it unlike our parents
worked in different uh domains and
different fields so we're
not really was exposed to it so i think
it's all about
uh exposing things and uh
get things into awareness
right and and i'd love to not to
understand a little bit your
your experience better because you know
i think that the experience of a
minority within a minority it's really
it really is an important one and i
think it's it's one that doesn't it
doesn't only meet you i guess
when when i'm interviewing you for a
podcast and asking me about it
but i'm sure it also comes back to your
daily life whether it's
you know when you come home and you and
you tell people that you're working on
something that is not necessarily
something they're familiar with from
your community
or perhaps when you're in the workplace
and and you know people feel that that
you may be a little bit different or you
may feel that you're a little bit
different
so tell me a little bit about your
personal experience uh and and how you
how you perceive this difference
they ask me what you do in your daily
job okay oh you're sitting all day
in front of computer you do nothing like
you're just sitting all day maybe
yeah so i have to explain to them
what i do i have to uh maybe use
some uh uh like you
like uh um really up real applications
and i say i do this
i eventually do this i connect all the
dots together and solve problems
uh complex problems and that's what i do
all day i'm sitting
and programming and it's hard to explain
and also there's uh an aspect of
investing a lot of time in it
it's a way of it's a way of life because
when you do
when you when you are engineer you have
to make it
uh your life and sometimes you find less
time
to invest in friends and family
you really don't have time and they ask
you
like why why you're not calling me why
you're not talking about your
uh like we're not seeing each other
enough and i need to explain that this
is my life
i can i'm i'm i really i really
it's all about this thing okay so um
so i try to invest in other aspects but
it's really hard
to explain to people yeah because we're
a small community kind of a small
community
uh so uh so yes it's
but it's but it's in the other way in
the other side
i love it i feel uh i feel it empowers
me
okay so it's really empowers me uh i
grow from it
because i have this support beautiful
yes very very cool and so susan tell me
a little bit about
the job of a team leader so uh you know
becoming a manager
through education and through being a
software engineer
the the responsibility of being team
lead yes
what is what does that mean to you and
how does it actually play in your daily
life
okay so being a team lead it's more like
for me it was kind of natural i always
even though when i was uh just coding i
felt responsibility i think
everything uh too close to me to my life
so
when i have some feature to to do
i really think about it all the time uh
so it's part of me
uh and this was nice i feel i felt the
responsibility uh
back then before i was a team lead so
for me doing this job it's kind of
uh natural so i do it like it's it's
it's not just a team it's not being it's
not really being a team lead you need to
work with the team so as one so i'm not
doing
everything but i kind of uh lead the way
um so if there's a problem i can help
solving this problem but i'm not doing
anything alone
so it's all about the team and the
people uh
so so i do it like
it's again it's natural i do it like my
daily uh
job i just don't think about it too much
very very cool and transitioning from
being an engineer hands-on you know
primarily coding to now
doing the what we're seeing a team of a
team of engineers yeah
right yes how does that balance it's
hard
because you still uh need to to
be because you still need uh to still
need to program or do
the engineer stuff in order to
keep being professional so
both aspects are very important to me so
i invest
both in both aspects i try as i as much
as i can to invest in both
aspects uh but again it may be maybe
it's uh
uh half uh being a team lead and
and the other half the time i'm being a
programmer or engineer
so it's both um it's i can say it's not
easy thing to do but you ha
you you just you need to handle this
right no that makes a lot of sense and
so susan
going back a little bit to to the idea
of impact and
you know part of a part of you know the
work that you're doing is already making
a positive impact but
from your perspective you know within
now this world what what needs to happen
to have more inclusion
and to have more more diversity within
the different minority groups
whether it's within organizations that
in high-tech organizations whether it's
in the education system whether it's in
the actual
you know places where you live what are
some tangible things that even young
people can do
to follow your path that you know yeah
you can learn coding
simply by you know look by using your
mobile phone
or any or any old laptop you don't need
the most
advanced technologies to learn how to
code today to get to the technion
and then to get into these amazing
companies yes
they again they have uh you need to see
a role model
okay so you need uh to see people in
this industry before you can do it
you need to um think big
you need to think big you need to again
to be open-minded so
you have to you just it's not going to
happen like this
you have to again i think you have to
invest in every aspect
to bring the jewish community inside uh
the israeli ecosystem or whatever you
call it so it's every in every aspect
in education uh uh in in the daily
like really uh know the uh uh the
language
maybe and being part of uh uh this uh
israeli ecosystem and uh
i really i really think it's hard it's
you need to work on it you need
more people like me so people can
see uh uh see us and learn from us
okay um
definitely yes and you know suzanne i
think that you know
the obviously that this is not the the
main thing that that you do in the
day-to-day i i
focused our conversation on this i think
primarily because it's a conversation
that is important to have and i think
that
you know part of being a role model is
also understanding a little bit
deeper you know your personal journey
and your personal perspective and
hopefully whoever is watching this
uh whether it's from the jewish
community or or any other minority
community
can feel empowered and understand that
yeah you know that anything is
and anything is possible and you don't
have to grow up with a laptop in your
hand
definitely and and i really want to
thank you for coming here and i know
that you're you're doing
incredible things that at code value as
well you know with uh we didn't have no
time to talk about it
graphic information with geographic
information systems and
image analysis and really really cool
things that i'm also really passionate
about but but i think we'll save that
for another episode
20 minutes go by very quick but i do
have a few
short questions about about you and and
i want you to take me back to your
childhood
and you know whether it's from the
education system or just from home
what what is what were some things that
you were passionate about as a kid what
really fascinated you
uh okay it's a hard question i need to
think about it but i think it's more
about
uh change and process like when you see
people
uh doing uh like i saw my parents living
their life and trying to handle
some difficulties in life and when i see
how they overcome things
uh for me it wasn't that easy at first
because i thought like yeah so so when
you deal with things in your childhood
you see your parents and you say how
they doing this like it's really hard
and i think they are my uh
my inspiration i i look at them and i
see how they
operate in the daily life and how they
care about us
at the same time they go to their jobs
and work and
come home so it's more about the change
the things that they
they they do over time and how they
achieve
things and how they overcome challenges
um it's more about that yes
amazing and um some inspiration for you
as you go along your journey
professionally or personally who served
as that inspiration
some inspiration for me um
okay it's really hard to think about
when you when you ask when you
when you when you like really ask this
question this way and you need to think
what are the inspiration for people
along the way maybe even somebody not
necessarily the role model but somebody
or something that
gave you some inspiration along the way
that looking back
okay you're thinking wow that made an
impact yeah okay so
i think um at first i was seeing things
differently like i was
i wanted to go to work uh to be
successful to do something important
but today i think about it differently
because
i see people around me smart people uh
that
see things differently and it wasn't for
me when i was
young i didn't think that way like for
like like thinking big
uh seeing uh really achieving uh big
things that you can do everything
whatever you want
and for me uh uh i worked in my daily
life i do
i really think that i can do everything
and it's just about
really doing uh this small job or small
feature in work but really influence and
do big things
and this is the inspiration i think for
me
very very cool and what are three words
that you would use to describe yourself
um maybe curiosity i'm a curious people
i'm a curse i'm a curious person about
life in general
and this is what really motivates you
find difficulties more as challenges
i can't describe it in three words but i
can like i can say that yeah
difficult is more as a challenge
maybe being interested in human behavior
uh behavior change
and all that stuff yeah uh and really
i'm a really
uh who sees technology as a tool to
bring a change
amazing yes amazing suzanne thank you so
much for your time
michael thank you for your inspiration
and for you being a role model for
others
and thank you for for sharing your story
with me stay safe and stay healthy thank
you michael